[Música]
i
gracias bien por presentarme
introducirme 1200 personas que me están
mirando fijamente y esperan que diga
chicos esperan demasiado haremos de la
tecnología
para acabar cuenta detalles clic clic
clic
cíclico
gracias a que link permiso ok tecnología
justa en quinto grado de primaria fue en
el instituto san alberto magno mi
profesora tecnología me dijo que la
tecnología era algo humanitario era
bonito ayudaba a gente yo le creí tanto
que cuando fui a jansen me metí a la
carrera electrónica porque quería ser
placas quería aquí ayudar a la gente
wikipedia la define esta manera
la tecnología me llama me estaba
quejando y mira cómo ven hoy y para ya
no defina de esta manera la tecnología
la ciencia aplicada a la solución de
problemas concretos yo la creí pero
chicos a mí la tecnología en últimos
cuatro meses me dio más problemas a los
que para salió en serio incluido ahora
en agosto es donde mi mamá me dijo que
iban a llevar una competencia del fiscal
les comento del principio estaban
escuela robótica fui a tomar agua volví
como ser humano normal cinco personas
estaban esperando una puerta y de
repente me comenzaron las en inglés
y yo estoy en argentina no solemos dar
en inglés en argentina del idioma
oficial creo que es español yo creo que
es el español no no no estoy equivocado
pero bueno dije tengo tres meses arriba
desde este domingo os voy a meterle
gracias gracias ahora les pasa
[Aplausos]
valera en inglés yo estaba asustada y de
repente mal además todavía en inglés yo
entendía nada y la respondía de domingo
de link o de link o
al final me comentaron hay posibilidad
de que te vayas a méxico yo dije si me
quieres voy hablar con tu mamá y ya
vienen las 11 decidiera la mañana de
halladay a las 11
ella fue espero que le hayan hablado en
español porque el inglés no sabe ni jota
así que el hablaron ella vino yo vine
todos vinimos y me dijo si te vas a
méxico
y será una semana en agosto tenía unos 4
o 5 meses por delante dije sí bueno para
una persona de educación secundaria toda
vuestra secundaria diría bueno no
importa
presentado que también iba a ir los
fines semanas a buenos aires y dije
bueno será al fin o semanas de agosto
imagino que sería lo normal para
prepararme buenos aires con nuestro mi
equipo el robot que tenemos que armar
hay muchas cosas que hacer si en un
finca lunes estaría bien sin vida
resultó que no mes
era desde ese día que me comentaron
hasta agosto
y yo dije bueno por lo menos ir en avión
no no no no era avión
ustedes se ríen yo que me estaba
queriendo morir
pero bueno paso
termina yendo todo ese tiempo entre
cientos 90 horas en colectivo y resultó
que conocí gente genial ya saben había
un políglota que venía de suizo se fue a
argentina después pasó ilegal en buenos
aires para irse a brasil tenía muchas
cosas que comentarme muchas formas de
pasar por lugares
también me encontré con ingenieros de
audi si la marca de autos estaba re
copado me habló acerca de su empresa es
muy bonito muy como resultado que se
caída de árboles cuando era joven pero
ahora está ingeniero podemos llegar
lejos chicos
bueno conocí gente genial y resultó que
bueno puedes saber que 190 horas ok
digamos que están bien que mi mentalidad
vistos obstáculos como formas de pasar
el tiempo casi o xavi como oportunidades
para hablar con otras personas
y si eso es lo que quería decir
e
podemos cambiar como reaccionamos tal
vez no lo que está pasando pero así como
reaccionamos a lo que nos está pasando y
son cosas geniales cabe de mentalidad y
percepción y por último metidos en los
problemas de hecho otra historia bonita
que les quiero contar acerca de la
previa previa previa a méxico estamos en
buenos aires y n6 al aeropuerto yo ya
había viajado un día anterior a buenos
aires y eso me costó ni tres horas de
sueño pero no las que hay las cuentan
estábamos eso hizo la una la mañana para
dos en aeropuerto tenemos que esperar un
volver a seis porque no obstante pero no
lo sé pero no los estaba teniendo así
que a las cinco en punto persona
señorita bien vestida hecha muy hermosa
y me dice ustedes son los que se iban
allá a perú y tórax cuando sí sí así es
estamos todos acá de la mañana esperando
así su vuelo se retrasa así nosotros
tengo una escala agregó y media y
nuestra plata lo que invertimos allí el
equipo como como lo hacemos que tenga un
día
bueno nuestro coche vino corriendo
después de media hora
aparecen 40 estaciones el tipo estaba a
pocos que ellos dicen chicos conseguí
una manera tenemos que ir a colombia a
bueno y en estas obras escalas 12 horas
ok está bien y ya está para nuestras
cosas a super resignados nosotros y nos
dicen
bueno tenemos que ir al otro lado del
huerto está bien amor del aeropuerto
cuando sea el vuelo en 10 minutos
nunca le di tanta utilidad a las horas
que corren educación física en serio
la escuela te prepara para todo hoy en
día
corrimos otra el aeropuerto nos fuimos a
colombia y sé que nunca salen bien justo
como ahora porque salimos afuera y
dijimos bueno tenemos un lugar viven un
minor hotel quizás deberíamos quedarnos
y dijimos nada para el shopping teníamos
una montaña
era un lindo lugar había hasta colombia
por aquí las montañas por acá allá
arriba una iglesia no sé quién va pero
no había mucha gente no era práctico
teníamos la montaña y fue un lugar
hermoso precioso para ver divino
o sea si pasan no nos podemos controlar
lo que nos pasa siempre los planeados
nunca sale bien acá aquí y miran pero
pasan y sacar lo mejor de cada esas
cosas en lo mejor
ahora lo que podemos también pensar es
que en el momento de hacer las cosas no
tiende a aprenderse truquitos del oficio
no soy un ejemplo ahora normal yo ya
estoy en electrónica creo que me gusta
por ahí y algo que aprendí es que el
soldador no importa qué tan desorbitado
está es el soldado nos agarra por la
parte caliente chicos
se agarra por el mango mango parte
caliente mango por el mango
no era muy buena antes ahora mejor he a
trucos del oficio
si cosas pasaron allá por ejemplo que
sacamos el robot de nuestras cajitas y
dijimos no no se ve muy firme vamos a
zarandearlo hasta que quedan todas las
piezas y volver a armar es lo que
hicimos en aseguran que esté bien todo
puesto al final ganamos un premio de la
seguridad
chicos yo no sabía que a seguridad tenía
permiso pero al parecer se vinieron más
gente vinieron gente de jueces cinco
jueces cada ratito venían a preguntar
cómo estaba el robado que era lo tocaban
ocho chabán les tratamos de dar el
control para que manejen no manejaron
bien tuvimos que volver a armar el robo
después de eso
pero son cosas que pasan
hay otra cosa que aprendimos allá que es
la humildad y la ambición si son para
ganar seamos sinceros argentina estuvo
ahí para ganar también
también tuvo noruega inglaterra rusia de
todo
y
fuimos pero en el momento eso se
acuerdan que les comenté que había unas
cuales que casi nos rompe el robot wear
también apareció en un hito de méxico
tenía todo todo está vestido de méxico
tenía la pintura de frida kahlo sigan
hitos de 7 años y tenía también en la
remera y también una especie de máscara
de un jugador de mucha lucha y él
apareció todo así dijo que sí y vino
corriendo tan agradable quería quería
llevar el robot de messi le hicimos el
robot para que lo lleven
y el diputado félix y cosas así son
invaluables
por ejemplo más tarde vimos gente que
estaba en conflicto bélico jugando
juntos estaban jugando de la mancha
mayor al estadio y era muy hermoso eran
cosas que no no les puedo demostrar
ahora porque no anda el power pero es
hermoso
también había gente que le ponía mucho
empeño como lucían por ejemplo les tengo
que comentar que los de australia
vinieron con palmeras en la cabeza
es un grano uniforme necesario y están
bailando con la cabeza
bueno se ganaron en un premio a la buena
onda yo lo hubiera dado igual también a
los indonesios que trajeron una especie
de para miren nutrias pero resultó que
eran lagartos
y lo pasamos súper bien fue muy
increíble o sea estar de tener ambición
pero suficiente de humildad como para
llevarte bien con gente que se supone
que tenga estar peleando con
ya con el mito que venía de méxico y nos
ganó que es local
la gente de indonesia o gente que está
en conflicto bélico que entre ellos se
llevan bien
otras cosas que nos dejan este tipo de
experiencias
es que si bien vas con una idea salir
con otra una de cosas que se te pegan
enseguida es la mente de un emprendedor
no un emprendedor es una persona que
progresa siempre permanentemente está en
su lugar de trabajo estaba en la escuela
por ejemplo estaba en la secundaria y
dije bueno es que la robótica vamos
vamos a hacer algo más aparte lo que ya
estoy haciendo y termina y todo estuvo
muy bueno pero quería seguir más me
busque más problemas así terminé donde
terminé en méxico en ese sentido y esa
es la idea de siempre como emprendedor
ya sea en el trabajo o como estudiante
siempre es un paso más adelante siempre
buscar otra manera de hacer las cosas
innovar tomar creatividad hay una
cantidad de cosas que podemos hacer ya
también
aprendemos a aprender permanentemente
permanentemente estamos aprendiendo
disciplinadas
[Música]
la educación van de la mano ya sea de
méxico no estábamos armando de vuelta al
robot de la nada eso no es que se rompió
mucho pero queríamos que esté
disciplinadamente genial y estamos todos
los días
ajustando tuercas que estén muy justas y
ha hecho una de rompimos la tuerca y
permanentemente hacerlo de su manera y
es ayuda alguna manera a mantenerte
sobre otras personas que no son
disciplinadas porque por qué
solo estás dando lo mejor de ti todos
los días exponencialmente vas creciendo
en ese momento también aprender es
increíble porque cuando eres
disciplinado generalmente aprendes más
cosas trucos los bises como iba diciendo
aprendes de todo y unas que terminan las
secundarias en serio no no hay que
quedarse ahí hay que seguir aprendiendo
la tecnología va avanzando nosotros
deberíamos avanzar con ellas somos
jóvenes ahora deberíamos aprovechar eso
para el pretendo rápidamente
hace años no existía internet ahora
existe internet hace años no existía
celulares con pantalla táctil yo tenía
nueve años cuando descubrí que las
pantallas táctiles no son de espías y
cosas así
creo que tenemos mucho por delante quizá
saber que iba después de los celulares
piensa en lo que pueda ver después de un
celular o sea que puede ser reciente
salto tecnológico
por eso
ahora
seguir avanzando seguir aprendiendo
permanentemente tener mente emprendedor
y también pero eso ya va más de gméxico
uno comienza a ver las cosas diferentes
y extrañar los momentos caseros por
ejemplo les presento la carne a la
naranja es horrible
no te va a gustar no las pruebas la
carne naranja es una carne que estaría
preparada para hacer un buen asado y las
ponen naranja y lo hierven
no me gustó la carne para mí en una
parrilla con sal y chimichurri así como
la carne para mí
pero bueno una de extrañar cosas así
como estás lejos de casa es normal yo
tenía mi facilitador marcos a lado mío
que por lo menos me ayudaba a hablar
cosas misioneras aunque sea escapar o
mate hace programa tantas personas ver
su cara de asco pero disfrutar tu maten
también ves gestos diferentes por
ejemplo y no traje para mostrarles pero
estábamos allá en méxico los stand
estaba uno de los otros son como parte
citas dónde está cada una sus países con
sus cosas favoritas y yo fui el último
donde había una chica y estaba el pósito
que sea sin va bueno si conozco el país
no es que otros países no los conocidas
pero sin más y lo conocí a una chica
estaba sola y estaba bailando sola con
música no nos sola del todo pero y tenía
una cantidad de trenzas así y yo vi
transitas y me parecían en lana no
trencitas así que fue preguntarle si
pudiera tocarle las trencitas por
curiosidad me llamó y le toqué las
trencitas y éstas te gusta de mis
trencitas ya que sirven tanto trencitas
bueno toma una
si yo dije gracias
pero doble persona
lo hizo con todo su cariño explicó que
la llevo tres horas que lo hizo
especialmente para el mundial así que ya
tenía tenemos en la mano y decía ay como
te agradezco les significa mucho para mí
pero bueno sí significó mucho para mí
porque ella se lo quitó de su cabello
para melo mí para mostrar el afecto que
me tiene y
bueno a mi mamá pensó lo mismo que
ustedes no están solos cuando vi la
transita
pero bueno de estos diferentes de esa
manera para la gente de áfrica en la que
yo conocí estas tres citas eran
importantes porque tenían costos que
representaban a sus culturas de
tradición también descubrí en méxico
otros tipos de culturas por ejemplo en
el tiene mucho mucho mucho cariño su
clase de indigenistas hay mucho mucho de
arte acerca de eso hizo fue genial
pero de una forma también extrañas lo
tuyo así que me volví a casa con la
transita y todo arriba
así que chicos creo que volvemos al
principio la tecnología se supone que
arregla cosas a mí me causó problemas
sigue haciéndolo pero creo que eso se
trata no de ver problemas ocupar lo que
tienes en el momento y seguir
sobrepasando lós de alguna forma no sé
si vas a pensar una calle de tratar de
no darte con los autos no es una forma
de pensar el solo de problemas pero de
todo tipo no sólo de problemas de
adaptarse crecer es exactamente lo que
llamaría hasta ahora que sobrevivió de
fuego hasta ahora que queremos ir a
marte es increíble como hemos avanzado
mucho como especie humana y cómo la
tecnología yo todo eso si tomamos la
especie humana como un grupo de monitos
que evolucionó y podemos tomar como
fábula y sacar la metáfora de la
tecnología creo que es un buen truco
para explicar nuestras vidas
adaptarse actualizarse permanentemente
estar aprendiendo aprender lo que tienes
que aprender afrontar lo que tienes que
afrontar porque ese man está preparado
una vez que terminas hacer está
preparado
y
sería preguntados en especial estábamos
terminando la secundaria todos acá están
en secundaria no levante la mano quien
no está en secundaria
gracias por venir
es que
muchísimas gracias por los de secundaria
y a los que están la secundaria
solamente quiero dejarlos ir ya
terminamos
cómo va a ser su próxima actualización
chicos si la etapa beta termina cómo van
a seguir después
los estaremos buscando todos ustedes
preguntas después muchísimas gracias por
dejarme pasar acá
[Aplausos]
[Música]